Maurice jones-drew NFL Network analyst
forum NFL running back
mojo part of NFL network's coverage
coming up this weekend of the opening
weekend NFL season mojo how are you I'm
doing okay I wanted to have you on for a
couple of reasons but first of all you
got a Zico Eliot missing all the
training camp I know he was working out
in Mexico how much does that matter at
that position that you you weren't there
for training camp matter I think every
situation is different you can't put you
know every player in one category and
say oh this is going to work out for him
or not and you got to remember zika's
miss time throughout the season
everything was suspended a couple of
years ago and came back and was just
fine so for me I I expected to be ready
to roll it's so funny everyone goes all
he's going to get hurt like how many
people got hurt during training camp
everyone right so ladies football that's
a part of playing football you guys get
banged up
so for me Syke understood his worth the
Cowboys understood is worth bouncing
with that contract I gave him and now
it's time to go get it and I think
having Zeke there and dak there that
their way in time rated at China when
there's East I don't know if you agree
with me but I said if you take away all
the quarterbacks and you were looking at
the most valuable player for a team I
said Ezekiel Elliott might be my guy
because you can go to the Super Bowl
with him without him you may not make
the playoffs what do you think of that I
agree 110 percent with yeah I'll vote
with all time we saw that the Cowboys
work without uzuki Elliott and that's
why Jerry and neither the Cowboys for an
office you worked hard to get that deal
done just because again like this is a
production based business you got to
produce and producing is getting
victories and so I want to say they won
one game we're something without a ZK
Latour and the numbers they were putting
up were just not even close in as much
as everyone loves Tony Paula he did a
great job as preseason he's not a zq
elliot so you wanted all that stuff
we also got our number two never first
year play caller and callee Marlin 4 so
yeah so telling more I mean you want to
make sure your play caller is
comfortable - you got to get all his
weapons out there and so he can be ready
as well so they they have some issues
but I think you know getting Zeke back
to help kind of get everything rolling
and I'm I'm confident the Cowboys to be
in that NFC playoff race here pretty
soon I'm wondering if we see this from
say Quan Barkley and Christian McCaffrey
what we saw with the Zeki Oh Elliot you
know like I don't think Chris McAfee I
think that deal done early okay but it's
a Quan Barkley gonna say two years out
hey you've used me for three years I
produced and I want to get paid now as
opposed to waiting for you know this to
come up and you know your franchise me
or something like that even in say coins
case I you would think that the Giants
would watch and see how those kinds
played out for the Pittsburgh Steelers
and out of Dallas Cowboys and the Los
Angeles charges that that is a
distraction and you want to make sure
that your player your locker room
understands like if there is no it's so
funny to me when I and I watch it when I
look at these teams and how they try to
run the organization you don't have to
play hardball with your best player
everywhere in the locker room knows say
Kwan everyone in the Cowboys lock
windows is ziget their best player on
the field just that's just what we know
is it when you're the Micra me you know
you see a very very okay he's the best
guy but if you don't treat him or you
know take care of him in those
situations other guys blog over like
well man if you did that to Zeke you do
it to me yeah I always try to I always
try to use other organizations like you
know their I call the Rams games on
radio but the way they've taken care of
their business it's unbelievable I mean
you took care of Todd early then you
take care of Jared golf early and my
Judas has played out to the media either
nobody would I didn't even know hey
Jared golf and I work for the
organization i Jared Goff was working on
an extension yeah yeah and so they take
care of it a certain way and guess what
the players in the locker room know -
Jarrett earned the right
he took them to the Super Bowl out for
two years every year they've got there
with McVeigh has gotten there it took
care of Todd Gurley because of the big
year that he having they take care of
their guys early so that there is no we
don't they don't want their players to
be upset they saw how it was when Aaron
was holding our place they didn't like
that and so they're like it's our job to
get ahead of the ball ahead of the curve
and try to take care of our players and
so I mean these teams that do this whole
thing like we're going to wait and try
to get you cheaper as you see now
players I mean first of all social media
allows you to see everyone's contract
there's certain people on social media
that you know the insiders and other
people that tell you what people are
making and and so you know as a player
where your value is and it's important
that the team sees that as well maybe
they switch the way they do business a
little bit why is the next quarterback
always the highest-paid player in the
game you know Jared Goff got paid his
dak Prescott gonna get more than Jared
golf just because he's the next man um
yeah I guess that's the way it goes it
should go like that I mean there's some
quarterbacks that got paid but shouldn't
have gotten paid a lot of money but
because of the next guy up they go but I
don't understand that mojo
that well I don't either but I tell you
what dak dak has earned the right to do
that dak has taken his team you know I
want to say since he's been the league
his the wins that he has since he's been
the league is right behind Tom Brady
which means he deserves the right to be
up there I want to say that you know dak
has proven to be a winner if you look in
that playoff game against Seattle he
took over he took it over in the fourth
quarter with his legs in his arm and
made some plays for them to win the
women when a playoff game so he's earned
the right to do it now I have to say
this because III do like go like get
kind of aggressive when I talk about
teams but close to Jerry Jones and the
Cowboys because they're able I didn't
even know Jaylon Smith was up to get a
deal done or Lyle Collins and so to find
a way to get all these deals done and in
a matter of what I don't know four weeks
yeah I mean that's a lot of hard work
that that Cowboys were able to do and
they they're able to get it done well I
think that they did those deals it
allowed them to free up some more caps
so they could get the seek deal done at
least that's what I was told but you
know I think that that it was lark yeah
I agree I and I you know everybody said
all Jerry's a hardliner you don't want
to negotiate with Geryon I went nowadays
I would negotiate against Jerry you know
25 years ago 20 years ago no I wouldn't
but I thought if you knew that Zeke was
was worked I don't know why it took this
long if both sides sort of knew what it
was gonna take you know maybe they just
Zeke did what he set out to do I want to
be the highest-paid running back I don't
want to be in training camp I want to
get you know 50 million guaranteed and
so maybe you check the boxes on all
those and it worked out worked out great
for both sides yeah you know I think you
know people are saying I don't know I
mean there's a couple writers that out
there on Twitter I don't try to throw
give them any recognition because
they're haters but you know I think when
you look at Zeke every player is
different and every organization is
different with those players so you may
not for example you may not pay you know
whoever at this organization because you
may have other pieces around them but
when it comes to the Cowboys you said it
best because what we call the Ginga
piece if he's not in there that whole
thing is caving down I don't care how
good your defense is I don't care what
your offensive line looks like
Zeke ele is not back there what is not
gonna win there's a couple other terms
like that as well what's more surprising
that the Raiders find Antonio Brown or
Antonio Brown told you what the Raiders
find him for missing those practices but
neither are surprising I think you know
I already we had known that the Raiders
were going to find them once you miss it
as a matter if those excused or
unexcused like the team is going to find
you know the key is are they gonna that
letter we all get those letters but
sometimes the teams don't you know they
don't follow through with the fine
though the real surprise is that you
know the deal he has with zennith
the helmet company you know I think that
was
traitor your own helmet is pretty nice I
wish I would have you know you know I
went through that manipro just so you
know I think there's like a bunch of us
that went through with the league like
takes away your helmet you have to find
another one what was wrong with yours
this was old I guess it was it was just
too old it was a helmet that I played
with I forget the name of it but it was
a helmet that I played with in Pop
Warner but I played with in high school
that I played with in college is exact
same helmet when I got the league and I
want to say until 2009 or 10 baby they
said you couldn't wear that hello
anymore and I was like no I play with
this helmet for my whole life like this
was like yeah I think I had that helmet
longer than I had some underwear and
socks you know what I mean I do think
players care more about safety health or
comfort it's all the same if you're
comfortable out there then you know you
feel safe right I remember wearing this
new helmet and I remember playing
there's a clip out there where I'm
playing against the Colts and someone
hits me and that we had an issue with
this Helen because we'll start to sweat
the new helmet sometimes they don't just
cuz it's new it's not like it doesn't
have the wear that not even aware but
just the the tightness of it I guess
wings are persuade it pops off well I'm
playing a game and I I go to score
touchdown it's a Colt and I get in but
by helmet pops off I get hit my helmet
pops off right and so that was some
bills are suddenly issues as you get
with new helmets it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what type of helmet it is
it's just the fact that you know it's a
new helmet and it has to get that wear
on the inside of you running in and
sweating ink and you know kind of
molding to your school a little bit so
it happens but again like I tried to
tell everyone I understand what Antonio
Brown was going through I mean Tom Brady
went through it and Rogers where we all
go through it at one point in our career
but there's a helmet that you've been so
comfortable with in the league says hey
you can't wear anymore get the turf on a
new one and then you got to make sure it
fits and it's tough I mean I just think
you know because hard knocks was there I
think because of the foot injuries the
helmet situation just end up being
bigger than what it was what are your
Super Bowl picks well you know you know
Miami is my favorite City
I told you that before I did not know
that Miami is one of my favorite cities
so I have to pick my two favorite teams
to go Jags and Rams hopefully they both
make it and then whoever wins wins I get
a Super Bowl ring you know you'll get
one from the Jags I mean I would hope so
why are you getting one I would hope
everyone would get one for the Jags all
right everybody all 25 you hear every
player from kids it's the first one
everybody get what I don't I don't think
it works that way
listen we're putting it out there in the
universal hopefully you know the the
Jags are listed okay wait wait wait what
would Blake bortles backup quarterback
for the Rams get a Super Bowl ring if
the Jags won I think he gets an
opportunity to get both as well why not
no you were great for them there's a
difference I know I know but yeah I saw
some stats on you mo here you go
yeah most rushing touchdowns first four
seasons in the NFL all-time you know
who's number one no Terrell Davis at 56
touchdowns first four years Eric
Dickerson Earl Campbell LaDainian
Tomlinson Adrian Peterson Barry Sanders
Emmitt Smith and Maurice jones-drew
wow that's pretty good you you and Jim
Brown tied at 49 touchdowns first four
years man close and then what happened
you know it's funny they I you know I
started to team we started facing some
teams that would you know put a lot of
guys in the box and we'd have to air it
out a little bit but it was still good
though well you still had one of the
great seasons by running back in history
when you were I think he rushed for
1,600 yards and everybody knew you were
getting the football and you still
somehow rushed for that
that total I would never Saul weighs one
of the more impressive seasons I
appreciate that and and I'm glad you
brought that up because I think a lot of
people look at just the running back
that do it but our receivers bought in
that year to block which was crazy right
saying I felt you wouldn't think
receivers would be out there blocking
but they did that in our offensive line
and everyone did a good job and asked us
you know we went through a lot that
season but that was one thing we could
salvage as a team and I still talked
about guys today about it so there's
something that we were able to do and I
have to thank everyone for that you
didn't his night he had six fumbles not
seasoned them oh yeah I was a because I
was trying to get somewhere I don't know
if you ever heard that have you ever
heard that term trying to get somewhere
yeah I was trying to get somewhere so I
was a little loosey-goosey with the ball
trying to try to you know get up out of
there I don't try to get there I get
there yeah but the problem dad's you
don't have 12 other guys trying to stop
you and I mean 12 there were 12 I'm
telling you I don't know if the rest
receded they put a 12 gallon field half
the time mojo I carry four guys three
hours a day in this man cave well you
should be strong you should be ready for
that we weren't you know we kind of got
adjusted to it towards the end of the
year I know what now hold on one of
those games was against the Panthers in
the and what we call the monsoon game
you remember that game remember it was
like it rain like we probably wouldn't
remember cuz and you know who's your
favorite team I don't have a favorite
team okay like winners we're playing
we're playing the peppers okay good you
like this one we're playing the Panthers
and I think this is Cam Newton first
year - more planted Panthers and in 30
minutes and rain six inches and we were
playing like in a lake at one point and
you know that back kind I think I
fumbled twice in that game that was my
thought it was right can't blame me I
blame the water
blame mother nature for that cam didn't
have any fumbles you gotta look at I
know you know who's the better running
back you or Cam Newton oh that's a good
one
um you know I think now that cams not
gonna be running anymore I'd have to
save myself I had a longer shelf life
but uh I mean it's it's tough man camera
six 1650 you know I was only 580 207 so
it's a little we had a two different
running styles bottom of Canton run the
routes out of the backfield though I
just think you know well your letter
you're a better passer but he might be a
better runner yeah I know how you know I
did throw a couple of three two passes
the league one that picked off one happy
hey great to talk to you and have fun
during the season we'll catch up with
you soon hopefully you know what and
before I go now that I think about it I
feel like the Jags owe me a couple of
dollars I did throw the ball a little
bit and the way these quarterbacks are
getting paid I mean I wouldn't mind to
check in the mill you don't I mean we'll
work on that and the Super Bowl ring my
man I appreciate you see you guys later
thank you that's Maurice jones-drew from
former pro bowl running back for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]